il ya une deuxième chose d'intéressant
c'est le vaccin pitre al aqsa j'avais
presque l'impression que vous frontier
la main pour les mains pour les
prochaines plate que vous pourriez
déposé layrac ça on va bien voir alors
on va bien voir quoi est ce que on va
poursuivre le ministre de la santé parce
qu'il a encouragé les vaccins ou est ce
que on va poursuivre la mise et la santé
parce que il n'a pas rendu les vaccins
obligatoires pour tout le monde il ya
trop de vaccins où il n'y a pas assez de
vaccins il ya des gens qui vous disent
le vaccin tu les anti vaccins liste des
vaccins tu es de gens qui lisent les
vaccins sauvent et en qui vous dit deux
vaccins sauvent mais il tue il faut pas
taxer les moins de 12 ans et c est ce
que notre confrère c'est une fois qu'on
aura la réponse est bien géré a déposé
plainte contre ceux qui se sont trompés
c'est ça non mais c'est ça la pervers
c'est ça la paix restent distincts et
vous vous vous dites et vous et vous
vous dites cher confrère c'est une
grande avancée de l'état de droit ben
moi je propose notamment celle des
danois je crois que c'est une grande
catastrophe et que oui bien sûr c'est
déjà le cas nous le savons les
gouvernants en place d'ores et déjà
s'inquiètent en disant est ce que si je
fais ça je vais pas avoir
une procédure nous avons déjà des
ministres qui prennent des décisions en
mettant qui le regarde par la fenêtre
s'il n'y a pas des juges d'instruction
qui viennent dans leurs ministères pour
perquisitionner comment est ce que vous
pouvez gouverner comme ça et vous dites
moi j'ai j'ai
administré une ville et je n'avais pas
peur mais le texte que nous avons lu
tout à l'heure
il a justement été écrit comme ça c'est
à dire de manière très restrictif pour
protéger les mères justement parce
qu'avant que la rédaction de ce texte
les textes étaient trop large et les
maires se retrouvait dans le tribunal
correctionnel à chaque fois qu'il ya un
accident dans une piscine ou dans une
ou dans une école et c'est pour ça qu'on
a fait ce texte pour protéger les mères
alors effectivement la mère maintenant
n'ont plus peur parce qu'ils sont
propres ils ont un texte et plus
protecteurs et on ne va chercher leur
responsabilité pénale que s'il y a une
violation délibérée d'une règle et
entraînant immédiatement un risque de
deux
morts
[Musique]